[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
Do you have a great cast
app that plays media back?
Well, I bet you'd love to know
how to engage your users more.
If I told you you could spend
a tiny bit more time coding
and get 20% more attention for
your users, would you do it?
Of course you would.
That's why you need
Autoplay and Queuing.
Autoplay takes
advantage of a feature
we've included in the
media playback library
called MPL preload.
You can get MPL to send
events back to your JavaScript
while media playback
is happening.
You can hook into those events
to gain more insight into media
while it's playing
back on a cast device.
For example, you
can get an event
when the entire media
has finished buffering.
But I'll bet you're asking why.
Well, if you're streaming
media over the network,
that event could trigger,
say, within 20 seconds
a video is still ready
to be played by the cast
device, which gives you time to
set up the next piece of media
to play so you can have seamless
playback of multiple media
streams one after the other.
Using MPL preload
can give your users
a great uninterrupted
media consumption
experience that they won't be
able to tear themselves away
from.
Now writing code to manage all
that can be time consuming,
so that's why we also
have Queuing APIs.
The queuing APIs let you
maintain a list of media
to play one after
the other, and take
care of setting up the
Autoplay buffering, et cetera,
so you don't have to.
The Queuing APIs also provide
dynamic playlist management
to make it easy to
display the queued meteor
items to your user, insert
or delete media items,
or change their playback order.
You can even show history for
media that's finished playing.
To help make a playlist
enabled experience enjoyable,
we provide [INAUDIBLE] about
how to inform your users when
another item is about
to start playing
with up next notifications
and countdown timers
to give your user a chance
to skip or cancel playback.
For reference, we've
added Autoplay and Queuing
to the example cast video apps
for Android, iOS, and web,
so you can see it in action.
Using Autoplay and Queuing
will engage your users
and give you much,
much better retention.
I'm Alex [? Deller, ?]
and I can't
wait to sit back and
enjoy your app delivering
me a seamless media experience.